morning everybody seven o'clock here in
the uk the pressure on the prime
minister showing no signs of going away
this morning after he was absent from a
key debate on mp standards on the show
today the justice secretary and deputy
prime minister dominic raab and the
shadow secretary of state for
communities and local government that's
steve reed plus we'll have the latest
live from the scene of a dramatic cave
rescue in the brecon beacons where a man
was saved after 54 hours underground
we'll talk to one of the rescuers this
hour in addition we'll wish guide dogs
to the blind a very happy 90th birthday
as we speak to a soldier who lost his
sight in iraq and his trusted guide dog
speak to him as well and
[Music]
adventure jordan wiley tells us about
the incredible series of challenges he
has just completed as he keeps his
promise to raise money for a school in
east africa it's tuesday the 9th of
november pressure on the pm as
opposition mps demand a criminal
investigation in the fallout from the
sleaze rhyme
we'll have the latest on the dramatic
rescue of a man who was trapped in a
cave here in the brecon beacons for over
two days
the mother of all mistakes claims in ivf
mix-up led to two women in california
giving birth to each other's babies
our memories of childbirth will always
be tainted by the sick reality
that our biological child was given to
someone else
[Music]
here in chennai and india emergency
services have already been deployed the
city is underwater and there is more
extreme rain forecast
supercourt in session
as the government tries to clear a
growing legal backlog caused by the
pandemic
also we'll have the very latest on the
um
travis uh
concert last weekend where eight people
lost their lives
[Music]
morning everybody try as they might the
government can't yet shake allegations
of sleaze over its handling of the
disciplinary vote against former mp owen
patterson one mp has now asked the
metropolitan police to launch a formal
investigation into the allegations
the story dominating many of this
morning's front pages for you i'm a
prime minister get me out of here writes
the metro as boris johnson is accused of
running scared over sleazed allegations
the eye focuses on the refusal to
apologize as he visits a hospital and
misses the earlier house of commons
debate
the times also pays attention to boris
johnson's skipping showdown in commons
as tories demand apology over the
patterson case
just say sorry for the mess the prime
minister headline on the front of the
express there and here's a flavor of
yesterday's debate
i would like first and foremost to
express my regret
and that to my ministerial colleagues
over the mistake made last week
we recognize that there are concerns
across the house
over the standard system
and also the process by which possible
breaches of the code of conduct are
investigated
when the prime minister gives the green
light to corruption
he corrodes that trust
when he says that the rules to stop
vested interest
don't apply to his friends he corrodes
that trust
well peter wizard of the smp who's
written to the metropolitan police
commissioner crested dick to open a
criminal investigation joins us now
hello thanks for joining us on the
program this morning what exactly are
you calling for sir
what i'm calling for is the metropolitan
police to examine the allegation that we
saw in the sunday times that you know 22
conservative donors have given 54
million pounds and all of a sudden have
found themselves in the house of lords
eight of the last nine tory treasurers
each have given three million pounds
have also found their way into the house
of lords now there's a very clear piece
of legislation dating back to 1925's
which says and states that it's an
offense to be awarded an honor for the
giving of money so what we're going to
do is ask the metropolitan police just
to see if there's any link between all
these conservative donors giving
millions millions of pounds to the
conservative party and finding a way
into the house of lords which is clearly
against the law
yeah you don't know that there is there
do you i mean there isn't necessarily a
link between the two things
well that's why we're asking them to
investigate
the only sort of outstanding
characteristic and feature of these
mainly gentlemen who have given all this
money to the conservative party is that
they have lots of money and have given
lots of money to conservative party they
may be there for other particularly
outstanding reasons and i note the
environment sector at the weekend saying
that they were philanthropists well i'm
pretty certain the british public
will probably rank the coffers of the
conservative party as a good cause which
is way way down in their priorities
why now
because what we've done in the course of
the past few days is the pandora's box
marked tori sleaze has been opened for
full examination and what a rotten
septic suspect we found that to be
so this is just one of the features that
we've seen all the way through this
we're now in the sixth day of examining
tori sleeves but you know the word
egregious gets kicked about a lot in the
last week there is nothing more
egregious than being awarded the place
in their democratic legislature being
able to
design and have a say in the democracy
of this country for giving money to a
political party
now i'm not accusing anybody of anything
all i'm doing is asking the metropolitan
police to have a look at this if it
breaks that 1925 act then these people
must be found
like they have they've been
found guilty of something so let's see
what they've done and let's see how they
get on
looking at your letters we're chatting
to you i mean your party's facing um
police questions over funding of its own
of course aren't you you're not entirely
clean i
just so i know there's a there's like
this temptation to try and include every
single political party when it comes to
all this you know
you're saying look at the tory party
over here they're completely guilty of
sleaze i'm just putting it to you that
you raised nearly 667 000 pounds since
2017 uh from its members and supporters
for several independence campaigns and
uh only admit to 57 000 pounds being
spent specifically on that campaign
excuse me and as a result um there's a
police investigation is that not true
i'm quite happy to discuss that with you
there has been obviously a complaint
about money that was given to the
scottish national party which is still
available for an independence campaign
from accounts which have been properly
accounted for and given to the electoral
commission so you know like people will
raise complaints and raise issues to try
and include everybody and all of this
but you know like
the it's the greatest bit of what about
the real issue and concern here is what
the public feel about what they've seen
the behavior as conservative in
government in the course of the past few
days that is the issue we've even seen
that reflected in the opinion postwar
labour parties now were taken to the
conservatives for the first time people
are concerned about tourist sleeves and
i know there's a temptation to try and
cast everything to look for any sort of
erroneous link
all i'm saying is so all i'm saying is
that exactly what's going to happen is
that you're saying all these toys have
got their noses in the trough and others
will turn around and say yeah but what
about you guys so i'm just giving you
the opportunity to clarify the situation
this morning i think i'm doing you a
favor actually
i have clarified that there is no issue
money was raised for an independence
campaign which will be spent on an
independence campaign the scottish
national party's accounts have been
monitored correctly by the electoral
commission and have been found to have
no issue and no difficulty people will
complain about anything i'm complaining
about conservatives treasurer has been
giving giving three million pounds to
the conservative party and seeing if
that's breaking breaking the law now we
can discuss this all you want but
there's nothing there
okay but it is still being investigated
by the police is that right
it's probably just a complete sentence
to be investigated yeah okay fine um as
far as um the leader of um your party is
concerned uh nicola sturgeon why is she
not um leading this charge
well it's a
a westminster related issue i am the the
shadow leader of the house for the
scottish national park and these sort of
issues tend to fall in the areas of my
responsibility so you know like i've
been leading for for the scottish
national party when it's come to these
questions in the past few weeks so i
think it's only written appropriately
that i picked this up
does she completely support you in this
oh absolutely i mean like i think you'll
probably recall k because you were you
were there back in
2005 2006 when the same issue emerged
with the labour party when
it was there was a suggestion that if
you gave a million pounds to new labor
you were rewarded with a place in the
house
of uh house of lords and tony blair was
even questioned under caution by the
metropolitan police on the back of all
that and it seems to me like very little
has changed and what's happened is that
you know the price of a place in the
house lords has gone up from one million
pounds from new labor to three million
pounds under johnson's tories
the house of lords is a rotten suspect
is the most absurd ridiculous
legislative chamber in the world second
only in size to the people's congress of
china
it has now been seen to be a place where
party cronies donors and placement are
poop
i think it's time that we call the call
the day in the house of lords we
certainly should be calling a day on the
fact if you're able to give millions of
pounds to political parties you find
yourself having a place that the
metropolitan police investigated and
indeed questioned the then prime
minister under caution nothing came of
it so what do you expect this time why
is it different well i'm hoping this
time it will be different i think what
happened last summer that was all the
evidence was presented we needed some
sort of cooperation to ensure that any
sort of prosecution could be taken
forward i'm hoping this time that
somebody emerges and tells the truth
about this to say yeah yes they were
told that if they were offering this
money that they may come forward we've
already had an anonymous source in the
sunday time saying that it's it's well
known that three million pounds gets you
a place in the house of lords now all we
need is for somebody in the course of an
investigation to say that to evidence
that then we're on to something now
that's quite possible that you know we
might not get that but this time right
i'm pretty certain and hopeful that you
know such as concern about the issues
around this that somebody will come
forward and help out with this
investigation and to see if we can make
sure it's progressed this time
sadly we're out of time it's good to
talk to you thank you for taking the
time to join us this morning thank you
now uh other news for you i should say
actually that we're going to be
interviewing the deputy prime minister
about 10 to 9 this morning and and we
will of course put some of those
allegations to him before that though um
appalling weather conditions hundreds of
rescuers though last night saved a man
with multiple injuries from a cave
hundreds of feet below the brecon
beacons becky johnson reports
in the darkness and driving rain the
injured caver was finally pulled to
safety
protected by an orange tarpaulin
carefully lifted into a mountain rescue
truck
only then did the team allow themselves
to celebrate
mission accomplished
the man an experienced caver in his 40s
have been stuck underground since
saturday lunchtime it took a team of 300
volunteers to rescue him from the vast
cave network
there is a sense of huge relief here
this the end of a mission that's lasted
almost 60 hours deep beneath the earth
here to bring this man out to safety
slowly steadily he began the journey off
the mountain to safety
everybody feeling i think everyone's
pretty happy yeah
yeah it's nice to feel safe
for the teams who've worked night and
day since saturday time to head back to
base
finally able to rest relax and reflect
on a successful rescue
i was here when the call out started and
i was very worried then would we get him
out alive or would he deteriorate um and
all saturday we worried most of
yesterday were worried so this is a huge
relief it's been a long long few days
and a lot of people very tense and so
the moment when that stretcher appeared
at the
entrance door of
um top entrance of one of the yeah that
was that was great
these are the kind of conditions they've
been battling this footage filmed a few
years ago shows the section of the cave
where the man fell
a specialist stretcher that floats on
water was used to carry him part of the
way
teams are prepared for rescues like this
this rehearsal shows the difficulties
faced in the vast cave system
including vertical drops making it
difficult to carry a patient safely on a
stretcher three two
one
but this is one of the toughest rescue
missions they've ever had to carry out
the longest stretcher carry in british
cave rescue history
the man has multiple injuries but they
aren't life-threatening his rescuers say
he's coped remarkably and will now get
the treatment he needs
well becky's with us now hi becky my
goodness me is a lucky man
yes uh waking up in hospital this
morning no doubt feeling incredibly
fortunate to be out of that cave network
we've been learning a little bit more
this morning about the nature of his
injuries and he will have been in an
awful lot of pain throughout that rescue
i hear he suffered a puncture wound
under his chin a broken jaw a lost teeth
a broken leg broken ribs and he had to
be transported on a stretcher through
this incredibly difficult to navigate
cave system for several kilometers
so the rescue team absolutely elated
last night i have to say i was with them
as they pulled him out of the cave i
think you know they do train for these
things but you know that there are cases
where these things go wrong the
conditions inside that cave
really really difficult there are some
very narrow passages
in some places it's filled with running
water really quite deep water in places
and there are those vertical drops that
they've had to navigate with this
incredibly injured man you can just hear
there the applause
as he was finally loaded into that
mountain rescue ambulance and brought
down here but you know this was a huge
rescue effort volunteers from around 10
cave rescue teams from across the uk
came down here they were taking shifts
to go under the ground they were
absolutely exhausted but one of them
said to me you know we're cavers we look
after our own and of course we were
never going to leave him there we were
always going to do everything we could
to get him out but yeah i'm told the man
he wasn't experienced caver it wasn't
his first time uh in the cave network
he's not local to here but his family
have been kept informed and he no doubt
feeling very lucky to be out yup
absolutely waking up in hospital this
morning thanks very much indeed becky
thank you
still to come on the programme for you
today we'll talk to the former miner who
believes far from being a villain
britain's coal mines can actually help
fight climate change those of course
coal mines in australia there just over
to six weeks to the big day so we'll ask
a leading logistic expert whether
christmas will be delivered despite the
ongoing problems in the supply chain
labor claims the government has
threatened to withdraw funding from the
constituencies of conservative mps who
voted against them in last week's
parliamentary debate on sleaze the
shadow community secretary steve reed
joins us later
before all of that though you won't
believe this story two couples in
california claiming a fertility clinic
made a series of mistakes which resulted
in them giving birth to each other's
babies
daphne cardinal says she and her husband
had been suspicious after she gave birth
to a baby girl they claim the clinic
involved mistakenly implanted an embryo
from another couple into them and
transferred their embryo into the other
couple both gave birth to baby girls a
week apart in 2019 and then swapped
daughters in 2020.
alexander and i are devastated
we missed an entire year of our
daughter's life
i didn't get to experience being
pregnant with her or birthing her
we missed her entire newborn period
we never saw our baby's entrance into
the world or cuddled her in her first
seconds of life
our memories of childbirth will always
be tainted by the sick reality that our
biological child was given to someone
else
and the baby that i fought to bring into
this world
was not mine to keep
when the truth came to light
it made exchanging the children all the
more heartbreaking
losing the birth child that you know
for the genetic child that you don't
even know
yet it's a truly impossible nightmare
that inflicted trauma
we thought that we were working within a
very professional industry
we trusted people
we trusted these people
and we never even knew that something
like this could happen they were just as
much in love with
with our
our biological daughter as we were with
theirs
so we've done our best to um
maintain a really close relationship
with them we've just sort of
which is really hard at first because
with total strangers you know it's like
how do you just become family
shingi's with us in the newsroom uh but
xing if you have tried and they want
each other to be an extended family now
don't they
they do they do but it's still an
extraordinarily sad and dramatic case
for that couple daphner and alexander
cardinale it all started in the delivery
room in september 2019 when they had a
child which they realized looked nothing
like either of them seven weeks later
they took a dna test and they realized
their worst fears that this child was
not biologically related to the pair of
them which kicked off a saga of months
long difficulty and trauma which they
eventually found out that their embryo
had been mixed up with someone else's
during an ivf procedure they're
eventually able to track down that other
pair of parents and in january 2020
three months old their biological
daughter then began living with them but
they've spoken extremely well in really
difficult circumstances about the trauma
that's caused them and their family they
have a five-year-old daughter who had
begun bonding with that baby that was
not their own they described it as a
living nightmare now because of all of
these things in the emotional distress
they're taking the la-based fertility
clinic to
a lawsuit
but i think it's also important to note
they haven't commented they have not
responded as of yet
the couple though feel like by bringing
this case forward and highlighting it
they can help stop this happening to
other people
okay thank you
can you imagine they trauma involved but
they're trying to make the best of it
and uh both sets of parents are now
getting together to make an extended
family wish them all the best going
forward um meantime emergency shelters
have opened in chennai as one of india's
biggest cities faces the threat of
severe flooding
let's get more on this now from our
correspondent katarina vitotsi oh
goodness me knee-deep in water there
katarina good morning
yeah good morning kay at knee deep in
water as you say but imagine this this
is the legacy from a downpour that hit
this city on sunday this isn't yet the
extreme rain that has been forecast
we're expecting extreme rain from
wednesday so that's tomorrow and
thursday to add to the legacy of what's
already been dumped on the city 24
centimeters of rain in an hour chennai
simply unable to cope with that volume
homes were evacuated schools have been
shut for the last two days just to try
and cut down on the number of people on
the roads but as you can see there are
some people who are still trying to get
from a to b still got public buses
running
going through water that is nearly up to
the step of that top bus let's um spin
around just so you can get a clearer
view of just how widespread this
flooding is
i'm going to step a little bit gingerly
myself as our whole team is because it
is extremely dangerous when you can't
see where you're walking you can't see
where you're driving we're told there's
an issue also with the power supply here
at the moment because of electrical
cables dangling into flood water so that
poses a health risk but really what is
the main concern for now is the
uncertainty of what is still to come you
know this isn't unusual to have this
sort of rain at this time of year here
in chennai it's the start of the late
monsoon season but what is oh just be
careful that dean there's a bit of an
edge there um what is unpredictable is
just how much rain fell in such a short
space of time and businesses are getting
ready they don't know quite for what but
they're expecting a lot of rain i mean
look at this shop here this is an
electrical goods shop it is just inches
away now from being flooding i mean
we've been here about an hour and a half
and already we're seeing in this
low-lying part of town all of the water
that's trying to drain away is coming
here and that shot well to be honest i
think if the rain continues like this
and gets even heavier as it's forecast
that shot's going to be flooded they
told us that they're preparing their own
sandbags they've not yet had help from
the government or the state ministry
although
emergency services have been deployed to
try and help people whose homes have
been affected uh all in all this city
preparing for extreme weather it can't
really cope it's been so um we've seen
the storm drains here of blocks the
water that we're seeing is a mix of both
rain water and drain water
it's pretty smelly it's very unpleasant
people are still trying to go about
their business but how long will can
they when this rain is just expected to
get heavier and heavier
yeah just looking at that couple there
that we're trying to make their way
through the water i think you referred
to them there katarina as they're just
heading uh towards our camera position
my goodness me what a challenge it is
for the local people at the moment
yeah i mean it really is but and you see
people that there's a lady here just
trying to pick her away and lots of
people are wearing sandals they're in
bare feet you know
they are used to this sort of weather
but not this sort of unpredictable
volume of water that is set to fall has
already fallen and will be falling over
the next few days okay katarina thanks
so much indeed thanks a lot
um and it's not the cleanest of water
given where it's been coming from not
just rain water that she's walking
wading through there and thankfully
she's got some waders on uh let's take
you to the italian city of venice again
been hit by flooding there as well
scientists say while the region is um
seeing typically uh seasonal high tides
the situation has been made worse by
rising sea levels caused by climate
change
it seems it's not enough uh to put off
some of the tourists though there you go
but many of the city's most famous
landmarks including scent marks square
there we are have been swamped by the
floods not quite sure why somebody would
sit down at those chairs and order a
coffee but they have um obviously um
embracing the situation in saint mark's
square in venice
just off one of the main canals there of
course
was that the doges palace i think it
might have been now day nine of the cop
26 summit in glasgow and no indication
yet of whether there'll be a deal on
greenhouse gas emissions government
ministers are being expected to be
involved in talks today and delegates
will debate claims from leading
charities that there is a big gender
imbalance in the climate negotiations
uh ashna up at glasgow forest hello to
ashnow we've just seen some of the
flooding challenges around the world
that's what they're trying to fix at
cop26 how they getting on
yeah they really are okay i mean it's
that eyewitness reporting that we've
been doing here at sky news that's
really been front and center of much of
the conversation here at cop 26 but
there have been some reports overnight
that china and saudi arabia are being
reluctant to be transparent over their
greenhouse gas emissions this comes amid
reports that negotiators are trying to
encourage countries to report accurately
the measurements when it comes to the
figures they've got around global
warming this some people are saying is
blocking progress with some countries
like china and saudi arabia not moving
on their perspectives it also comes as
research has come out from campaigners
global witness that 503 people who are
here at cop 26 are associated with the
fossil fuel industry collectively that
makes them bigger in delegate numbers
than any other country here in
representation so raising a few eyebrows
here in glasgow um but it is science
innovation and gender day as you
mentioned kay focus very much on women's
groups but also
on innovation the future technology the
future green economy we've heard this
morning and that uk company rolls royce
is uh has had a huge amount of
investment from the uk government some
210 million pounds both
this will be private
funding we understand that this is going
to create
miniature nuclear power stations we
understand these are going to be cheaper
to build because they're going to be
made in a factory but also hopefully in
the long term in the short in the
not so distant future sorry these will
be implemented and be used by the 2030s
for the uk economy it's good news
because it could mean some 40 000 uk
jobs but also it does help towards that
greener future so a bit of a mixed bag
here here in glasgow but good news when
it comes to the future of green energy i
left you as custodian of that living
wall how's it getting on
um it's getting on okay not not too bad
not too bad but um yeah hopefully it
will uh withstand the rest of the week
there are some um lots and lots of plans
uh here in glasgow over the next few
days so hopefully then yeah it'll stay
strong i'll be there on friday and
checking on it thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot ashna
a couple of guys that actually come
every day to clean and water that and
they do a fantastic job this is what's
happening as far as our dashboard is
concerned uh left-hand side top corner
that's how much hotter we are as a
climate as a planet i should say since
1880 birth of the industrial revolution
uh the bottom left is the amount of co2
emissions in millions of tons and then
to the right hand side that is how much
our real-time power mix is just at the
moment renewables doing pretty well at
the moment look at that hardly any coal
at all talking to a coal miner later on
on the program
let's have a quick look at the winner
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
patchy rain sinking across uh fizzing
out as it does so and some heavy showers
will rattle into the northwest this
morning is much milder than it has been
recently but it's also rather breezy
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
the chief of police in houston has
revealed he told the u.s rap star travis
scott there were concerns about public
safety ahead of the concert in which at
least eight people died in a stampede at
the weekend
in a statement troy feiner confirmed he
met the star and his head of security
ahead of the incident in which hundreds
of people were injured at the astro
world festival in texas the rapper is
facing multiple lawsuits a lawyer
working on behalf on a number of victims
says other relatives are also
considering legal action
we will be filing a lawsuit on behalf of
35 plaintiffs
that number is growing
our phone is running off the hook
i think it's self-evident
that this concert was planned incredibly
poorly
that no regard was given to the safety
of these young people at the concert
that there was no emergency response
mechanism in place to help those
who were in an extremist situation
there was not enough medical personnel
enough security personnel and there were
more people there than should have been
there
also making the news for you a
ten-year-old boy has died after reports
of a dog attack in wales gwent police
say paramedics were called to the scene
in kefir yesterday afternoon but were
unable to save the child the dog was
later destroyed by armed officers
more than half of women in the uk saw
changes to their menstrual cycle during
the pandemic researchers at trinity
college dublin found a significant
increase in reports of painful and
missed periods compared to before the
lockdown
scientists blame the changes on what
they called an unprecedented
psychological burden
residents of a town in romania had a
lucky escape when they were invaded by a
pack of badly behaved wild bears here
they are cctv from the town of sinai
show people being chased down the
streets
by the bears
it's thought the main culprits were a
hungry mum and her cub romania has one
of the largest wild bear populations in
the world with an estimated 6 000
roaming hello looking over the fence uh
roaming through the country there they
are this watch this lady she realizes
that no that's not a very good way to go
and here comes mummy bear
chasing
her yeah look at that look the bear
chasing that woman now could coal mining
actually help fight climate change she
will be joined by a former miner who
believes so in just a few moments
[Music]
now despite an apology to the house of
commons the government is still facing
allegations of sleaze over its handling
of the disciplinary vote against the
former mp owen patterson one mp has now
asked the metropolitan police to launch
an inquiry into the allegations peter
wishart from the snp says he believes
there should be a criminal investigation
what we've done in the course of the
past few days is the pandora's books
marked
has been opened for full examination and
what a rotten
septic suspect we found that to be
so this is just one of the features that
we've seen all the way through this
we're now in the sixth day of examining
tori sleeves but you know the word
egregious gets kicked about a lot in the
last week there is nothing more
egregious than being awards the place in
their democratic legislature being able
to
design and have a say in the democracy
of this country for giving money to a
political party
how far are they going to get tomorrow
morning kate well the snp are very angry
about this story about conservative
party treasurers and donors getting
places in the house of lords which
they're linking to the wider sleaze
issue
parliament yesterday debated the owen
patterson debacle steve barkley a
government minister apologized but boris
johnson was 300 miles away in
northumberland and didn't want to
apologize while he was there visiting
hospital and he didn't get back in time
he said on the train to make that debate
and there was a lot not true though is
it because he could have got back
the debate did go on for some times i
think he could have probably made it but
there was some interesting levels of
discontent from tory mps including a
former cabinet minister who said when
the captain of the team makes a mistake
he should come and apologize and i think
while this standard issue rumbles on
it'd be interesting to see how that
discontent with boris johnson's failure
to apologize um has an impact on the
conservative party i mean we did look at
the train times and we did look at the
time that the debate finished
just saying um talk to me about super
courts that's right i interviewed
dominic raab yesterday about courts
because the the backlog in the crown
court where all the most serious cases
rape and murder and so on are done is
sixty thousand partly because a lot of
trials had to be put on hold during
covid but lawyers would say also because
of a buildup of spending cuts and other
difficulties when i asked dominic rob
when he thought that backlog would
return to normal levels he said it would
take years i put it to him that maybe
seven or eight years this is my
report when the call went out last year
for venues to host a backlog of court
cases the team at peterborough cathedral
was one of the first to respond there's
the old ad is that justice delayed
is justice tonight and we hope glad to
be able to help we've had some fraud
cases here we sometimes see journalists
outside when there's a really salacious
case
with a few new accessories this 800 year
old room can accommodate a socially
distanced judge and jury
this cathedral and dozens of churches
hotels and theaters offer themselves up
as nightingale courts to hear cases
during the pandemic and many are still
going because covid and a build-up of
spending cuts have left victims waiting
years for justice
lisa not her real name worked up the
courage to report a sex offense which
happened when she was a child it was
three years and several cancelled
hearings before the perpetrator was
jailed this year at one point i actually
wrote a letter to the judge to say
actually i feel like i'm in prison that
the you know the trial keeps getting
getting cancelled i felt like i was
serving a prison sentence
it has destroyed my personal life
it has just yet you know i was going to
move house back in december that hasn't
happened and i had plans to adopt that
hasn't happened everything has been on
hold
um because i didn't want this man to be
able to do what he did to me to somebody
else
today a new super courtroom opens in
loughborough to accommodate cases with
up to 12 defendants in the dock we put
lisa's case to the justice secretary
dominic raab who said the new court
would free up more space to get through
other serious cases like hers
well i totally understand that on top of
the appalling crime that they've
suffered they've got the extra anguish
and ordeal of this weight in limbo which
is exactly why we're pushing a billion
pounds across the court system to get
the wheels of justice whirring back uh
like normal now the treasury gave you
some more money they expected the
backlog to be 53 000 in three years time
so at that rate we're looking at seven
or eight years to get the backlog down
is that an acceptable time scale i can't
tell you with any precision exactly when
we'll get back to pre-pandemic levels
but i'm confident that within six to
twelve months at the very latest we will
start getting the backlog coming down
for those in the system many of those on
the long road to getting justice feel
they are the ones on trial tomorrow
cohen sky news
and we are going to be chatting i think
to dominate roblox aren't we yes he's
coming on for the government to defend
the owen patterson case and wider issues
of sleaze he and the prime minister were
both i believe not at the debate
yesterday and he'll be talking about
where they go from here and what is the
standard system going to be in future
because we currently don't have one okay
um thanks very much tomorrow thanks a
lot tomorrow's take of course at nine
o'clock as well looking forward to it
well as the cop 26 talks progress
there's criticism of the agreement on
coal two of the biggest producers
australia and china have not signed up
to the deal to phase out coal power are
they right joining us now is chris
kitchen general secretary for the
national union of mine workers hello
team mr kitchen thanks for joining us on
the programme this morning what role is
there uh for the future of coal
i think there could be a few a role for
the future of coal within
protecting us environment and reducing
co2 emissions
we know that um calm capture and storage
will have to be developed and deployed
to gas power stations
and if we had just protected as core
industry deployed the cam capture and
storage to the
coal power stations we would have had a
secure and affordable supply of energy
going forward
but isn't coal one of the uh may or used
to be one of the major emitters um of
the carbon emissions that we're so upset
about now that are causing so many
problems for us going forward
it did and unfortunately as part of the
privatisation of the uk coal industry we
we closed the research development down
that was going on into
burning coal more efficiently more
cleanly which would have contributed to
reducing carbon emissions there just
seems to be
you know
politicians talking about it but they're
looking at what political capital that
make for him
experts that are looking at reducing co2
but they're not looking at what other
potential issues they're going to create
by putting in place the policies they've
got we need common sense into the
argument
if we're going to win this and we need
to get buying and unfortunately the uk
coal industry and outwards decimated
is not a good example for to show to
other countries when you're asking them
to close down their coal industries
we've also got a legally binding
agreement with the uk government that's
got to supply concessionary fuel
to form a coal miner so if they're
successful in closing down the corn
stream in the world how they're going to
abide by that legally binding agreement
to supply concessionary fuel to former
coal miners in the uk
except we only produce i mean the amount
of coal that we use in the united
kingdom at the moment is generally about
2.2 percent looking at our climate
dashboard this morning it's less than
one percent
appears that although we were wedded to
coal and we it was we were desperate for
it in the 1970s and 80s if we didn't
have it we couldn't heat our homes the
lights didn't stay on it's not the case
anymore
no that's not the case anymore because
the decline in the coal industry that
was a politically motivated vindictive
act to shut the industry down and that's
been detrimental to the to the country
you've now seen you've also seen the
rising
energy prices as we become more reliant
on gas and much of that imported
that the price has shot through the roof
the people this winter that will be
doing more toward to combat climate
change will be the poor people because
they're turning the heating down not
because they want to
be environmentally friendly but because
they can't afford to keep the the
heating on
but coal is dirty and it also claims the
lives of coal miners doesn't it
no the burning of coal
is what causes a problem there is
mitigation that can put in place with
carbon capturing stories that's been
trialled in other places in the world
and we were
a world leader in that technology
it's the burning of the fuel it's not
it's not the mind of the fuel yes the
you know the coal industry was a
hazardous industry we did have
a lot of accidents and unfortunately
fatalities
but we were one of the safest coal
mining countries in the world
um we are where we are we don't have
very many coal mines uh left so do we
just have to accept that whatever the
argument back in the 80s whether you're
on the side of the the then government
or not we we can't return now to colby
and king
no i think we've there's a
coal mine in west cumbria that's looking
to be open back up
it stuck in planning even though it was
given planning by the local planning
authority but it's been called in by the
government
that's cut for coking coal and the
government you know keeps saying that
they're in favor of retaining the
british steel industry
so it seems like a common sense approach
to combating climate change to to mine
his own caulking coal from that mine and
transport it and use it in our steel
industry as opposed to transporting
halfway around the world
and then burning it over here and like i
said before it's the burning of it that
gives off the co2 not the mining of it
thank you very much indeed for
explaining that to us on the programme
this morning thank you
thank you thank you thank you
uh very sad news reaching us this
morning about an amazing guest that we
spoke to a couple of months ago you'll
remember him alex flynn
he has died as he was on a trek to the
himalayas and mount everest to raise
money for research into parkinson's
disease
the adventurer was diagnosed with a
condition at the age of 36
in a statement his family said he went
out exactly how he would have wanted to
off the high of having completed another
adventure on top of the world
alex was undertaking the expedition to
raise money for the charity parkinson's
dot me the not-for-profit aims to give
positive support and advice to families
affected by the disease
now brexit and the pandemic have been
blamed for the ongoing uh supply chain
problems supermarkets still reporting
empty shelves and transport companies
are offering increasing salaries to
lorry drivers so will christmas dinner
and the presents be delivered on
alex march is the uh deputy director of
public policy at logistics uk hello
thanks for joining us how about is it
out there has it got any better
yes it has got better and it's getting
better all the time we're seeing more
and more drivers come through to work in
our fantastic industry
we've seen the government double
its capacity to test candidate drivers
we've written with the government to a
million people who have an htv licence
to encourage them to get back to driving
and there are many more measures being
taken both by industry and government to
encourage people to get back to it to
join it
and we are
confident that this is a resilient
sector that will deliver what people
need at christmas
and there are some novel ways of making
sure that we get things like booze
around isn't there i think there is uh
extra trains being laid on to bring in
uh christmas boos that sort of thing is
that right
yeah well listen the wine train has been
a thing for many years in the logistics
world it's normally one of the things in
our media bubble doesn't get a lot of
attention and i'm glad you're talking
about it because
um it's not the only one you may not
know this but wine comes all the way
from australia and new zealand by ship
in specially controlled refrigerated
units so there's all kinds of innovative
ways that the logistics sector meets the
challenges that meets customer demand
we know the government's looking at
making more use of rail at the minute
which is fantastic and we also know that
we're building back the workforce to
deliver our domestic supply chains and
get christmas delivered
and when the boats get here can they
dock at places like felix
stone
yes docking isn't so much the problem
it's more about have we got enough
people and enough
equipment to move the containers off the
port now um that is another symptom of
the driver challenge
it is moving on uh what we've got to do
is keep the throughput of people joining
the industry
um we didn't get as many work visas as
we wanted but the government has now
introduced a rule to allow
foreign hgv
drivers and companies to make more
domestic trips than they normally do
that's something that we decided not to
oppose
and provided that it has no impact on
the market for domestic haulers
so with that
and the additional capacity that's come
through
through the better testing and the
better wages on display
we are confident the ports will get
cleared and that christmas will have the
minimal disruption possible
and are european drivers coming forward
because they didn't really did that i
mean the government was looking for
something like 5 000. but at the last
county it was about
26.
well the visa provision was limited
anyway because it was only for drivers
working in food or for fuel it was 300
for fuel and 4 700 for food and we
actually don't have
figures on the uptake
but i think perhaps the more effective
measure is going to be
moving um the allowing foreign drivers
to take more
journeys when they're in the uk when
they drop something off
they'll be able to do unlimited trips
for a two-week period
which normally is something we wouldn't
like to see because it's damaging to uk
haulage but there's so much demand out
there
that um talking to our members we felt
on balance not to oppose it because it
provides extra capacity in the market
that's a temporary measure for six
months so that's probably going to be
more helpful than visas what we want to
see on visas is a long-term pragmatic
review across the whole economy to see
which of these so-called level two jobs
um should be allowed to get a long-term
skilled worker visa and it's not just us
saying that it's the care sector it's
hospitality as well i think that that
needs long-term reform but that's not
going to be quick enough to help for
christmas
okay alex we are going to dub you the
guy who saved christmas this morning
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you
thank you
now the canadian city of vancouver has
been experiencing some extreme weather
in the last few days
um have a look
officials from environment canada
confirmed these pictures showed what's
known as a water spout over the region
at the weekend for a while they were
warning of severe and potentially
weather